good morning I have a slight cold
is not usually as deep and interesting
as this so today we're going to talk
about reading other people's code and
this is something that we all have to do
a lot of the time and very often
especially trying to learn a brand new
code base is very hard
so first Who am I my name is Patricia oz
I am currently a consultant I've worked
on many in many different big code bases
the first one I worked on after
university was at Opera Software where I
worked on the opera desktop browser and
then I was a consultant for a couple of
years working mostly in Java been
working mostly in C++ most of my career
and then I went to Cisco where I worked
on embedded telepresence systems for
five years and then I went back to
making a browser again after Ivaldi
where I work to live Ivaldi browser so
six months ago I started working for
myself at my company was just called
Theriot second so a little bit about
what we're gonna go through today just a
little introduction and so you got
somebody else's code then some tips to
to get started then we're gonna go
through ten techniques on things you can
do to navigate the codebase and then
we're going to look at the other end of
this how are you going to if you is this
is your codebase how are you how do you
need to think to receive a new
contributor into your project so you got
somebody else's code and very often
people are very skeptical to code that
is not their own code because you know
we are used to the way that we program
and we have a tendency to be more
skeptical to other people so the most
important thing when you're approaching
somebody else's code is to think that
this is not a code of view in this case
what you are going for is trying to
maybe add a feature understand how it
works maybe become a contributor in this
project something like that they
has one of the things that's important
to realize is that if you if you are
looking at the code with a critical eye
you won't learn because if you come with
it to to learn you will learn but if you
approach to criticize you will criticize
and and that's it's it's a very strange
thing and you will see that in code
reviews as well that code reviews have a
tendency to split on the people who know
the area really well they have a
tendency to look at functionality
whereas people who don't know the area
very well have a tendency to look at
syntax or style so this is a quote from
a very famous old book called how to win
friends and influence people by Dale
Carnegie and it says instead of
condemning people let's try to
understand them let's try to figure out
why they do what they do that's a lot
more profitable and intriguing than
criticism and it breeds sympathy
tolerance and kindness and I say this
way way up front because we have a
tendency when we approach a new Co based
and you'll often see this with new
employees that come into your company is
that they'll start off really critical
and the thing is if you want to
contribute to a new project you want
these people this team the the people
who maintain this project you want them
to like you so approaching it with a
curious eye with a learning attitude is
is much more conducive to making people
like you than coming in and criticizing
them but first of all I think it's
important to think about what it means
to approach code that is not your own in
to me I in my mental model code is a
serialized version of a mental machine
when I program I have an idea on how I
want things to work when this thing
happens this thing here should happen
and then it kind of flows in this mental
machine I have a mental model it's very
visual to me but to program I have to
serialize this into code it has to
become classes and functions and in
interfaces and layers and and this
serialization process is fine when it's
my own code
uh I can also when I read my own code I
can see the Machine and I can make
adjustments and if I get a patch of my
own code it's much more it's much easier
for me to map that to my own mental
model and just say oh yeah but that's
not gonna work because of this thing
over here but when we approach somebody
else's code we don't have that mental
machine we don't have a model and how
it's supposed to work and and this is is
interesting because we have a tendency
then to think that there's something
wrong with the code because we don't
understand it because we don't get that
feeling we usually get when we looking
at our own code we now it's just files
on disk possibly hundreds or thousands
of files on disk and it just feels like
okay so yeah I cloned the project what
do I do now and also the fact that that
running code is not linear if you run
the code it's going to be jumping around
from different files it's going to be
like okay so you start up here maybe in
Maine if that's your language and then
you you hop around from different
classes through different layers of
abstraction it's not linear it's not
like you've got one file you can start
at the top and read to the bottom also
starting at the top and reading to the
bottom of a code base doesn't scale you
couldn't try to read code when it's a
small project you know a couple of files
you can try to read it all but the
moment you end up in bigger code bases
and I've seen some really big code bases
this doesn't work Vivaldi way to include
the chromium code base has 600,000 files
there is no way you can read it all even
if that was your sole goal for your
entire life you sit down and I'm gonna
read it from start to finish and also
you know the whole project would change
we're reading it right so we need
techniques that scale on bigger projects
and bigger code bases
okay so before you start there's certain
things that you um you should do to set
yourself up to be more productive in the
other techniques but not only getting
started
or not only like before you start but
also getting started because very often
it feels very intimidating
approaching a new codebase and you don't
really know how to start and it becomes
like a thing and then you don't know
what to do and they need to go take a
coffee so these things are things that
you know how to do so first of all get
the code on your machine some people try
to do this like online like you know the
code is there I can just browse it on
github or whatever it's it's really
impossible to to really deep dive in a
codebase if you don't have it locally
because when you have it locally you can
do stuff like you can put it into source
control if it wasn't a source control
already then you can but the thing that
you can have now so you can make changes
and you can easily roll them back
because what you will often do is you'll
add some stuff places like do I get here
what happens if this one is different
and you will make changes but then you
know you've probably break something or
it's not interesting anymore and then a
hard reset is possible then you probably
want to put it into the smartest IDE you
can afford because then you can leverage
the ID for for all it's worth and then
you want to fight figure out how to
build it because if you can build it you
can run it which is a feature because if
you can run it and you have it in a
debugger there's a lot of things that
and that are now available to you like
setting breakpoints and stepping through
things and inspecting runtime State and
also I would actually say try to figure
out how to run the tests because if you
can run the tests and maybe add tests
then that is a way to figure out how is
this application exercised what are the
different ways that it is exercised and
then maybe set up something that
addresses the use case that you're
looking at
okay so why would you do this well
usually you would have like a good
reason like let's say that you had an
exception in your project or something
ended up in your logs and you didn't
understand I do you googled it and you
didn't have any hits on Stack Overflow
and suddenly now you're like okay so I
have to check out this framework that we
depend on apparently and tried to figure
out what is going on but sometimes you
just want to contribute to a project to
learn something maybe or you want to
make some documentation for this project
which is a really good start in getting
people to like you if your first pull
request your project is refactoring
their API or some part of their their
project they're probably not going to be
very happy it's it's not a very good way
to get on somebody's good side but if
you come and your first pull request is
for documentation people are usually
really happy and that's a good way to
get people to like you but also you
might want to teach others there might
be some dependency that you have in your
project that other people in your
projects don't really understand either
so if you sit down and you learn it then
you can try to have like an internal
presentation teaching it to others maybe
even go on a conference and hold the top
but code if you look at it like all of
the files on disk is basically balls of
yarn on the floor all each thread is
basically a thread of execution but it's
all a big mess and trying to figure out
how it is all hooked together is
basically where do I begin I mean you
could start anywhere somewhere do I
start
so basically the whole idea is fine and
interesting and then you pull on it and
an interesting and could be many things
so I will go through how to do that but
the basic process that I'm going to
describe is is iterative so you you go
through things you establish a vague
outline the new flesh flesh it out by
trying different techniques and I really
would recommend taking notes
and drawing things just because it's
it's complicated you don't know it and
as you move along you will learn things
that that when you read through you know
to go like ah okay so that's why that
was that way okay so the ten techniques
or finding an interesting hand to pull
on are and I'm going to listen I hear
and then we're gonna go through them I
have one by one so the first one is
grabbing then where is this button
following input events what do the tests
do refactoring reading main the
graphical layout runtime investigation
reading a class and retelling or rubber
ducky okay so let's look at grepping
first gripping is an interesting thing
because it is something that we all do
but we don't really like to talk about
because it doesn't feel like engineering
it feels sort of like random you're like
okay so I don't know how to start and I
have this string in my error log okay so
I'm just going to grab for the string in
this massive code base and see what
happens and the thing is it doesn't feel
like engineering but it is a massive
part of learning in another somebody
else's code and it is a very important
technique and you shouldn't be ashamed
of it so you find the string that is
interesting to what you want to look at
now that could have been in the glee it
could be something that you see when you
do help on a command line tool or it
could be in the logs right any kind of
string that you see that you find
interesting and then you just grep for
it and you figure out where it is in the
code base this this technique is used in
many of the other techniques as well for
finding stuff but oftentimes it might
not be like a literal grep it could be
like find usages or something like that
using your ID so one place that we can
use that is in wearing this button where
is this button
so here you have the text on the button
so if you have a GUI application you
have
button and there you go like okay so
where is the code for this button and
then a good idea is to wrap for the
button text hopefully it's not like okay
because that's kind of everywhere but if
but if you find it but that has a little
bit more text on it it will probably be
a unique so grab for the button text
then you find you will generally find
first you'll find the text in the
localization file if you have like a
localized application and then you'll
find some kind of constants and you grab
for the constant this is like a process
then you find the button definition
somewhere once you found the button
definition then you try to find the on
click and it's usually around the button
definition someplace and then you set a
breakpoint on this now of course to be
able to set a breakpoint basically
you've done it basically almost all of
the free steps so you have it in the
debugger so you're able to set a
breakpoint on it and then you can leave
the button the good thing is that the
moment your breakpoint hits you suddenly
have a lot of information you have the
information on the runtime state at the
point when you click the button and
there's a lot of things that are in play
at that point the whole UI is up all of
the all of the inheritance hierarchies
or the the widget hierarchies are up and
you can start inspecting those you can
also look at the stack and you can
figure out okay so how our events
propagated in this application like how
where do they come from and who did they
pass through so there's a lot of things
that you can do but also you can also
Traverse up the widget hierarchy and
this will show you how the the UI is
structured the button will be on a view
plane the view plane will be on maybe in
the dialogue the dialogue will be a
child of a window and that will give you
an idea on the actual structure of the
URI and then you have so that is more
like a top-down approach then you have a
bottom-up approach which is following
input events following input events is
something that is useful if what you're
looking at is a GUI framework so if
you're trying to figure out how your
glue framework
works then then this technique is very
useful it's based on two interesting
things about GUI frameworks they have
two things they have to do they have to
feed input events from the platform to
whatever widget has focus and they have
to or or to any widget that email if you
mouse over something to give it a mouse
effect or if you click on something
whatever was clicked on but the other
thing that Akulina framework has to do
it has to produce a frame that can be
shown on the screen and these two things
are are true for all GUI frameworks and
and trying to figure out where that
logic is will lead you to the heart of
the framework because good frameworks
are massive so trying to figure out what
is the central components to figure out
how it works trying to trace these two
things where is where is the output
frame coming from and where are the
input events coming going in that will
lead you to the core of a GUI framework
and that's an easy way to try to figure
out how it works and that's also where
you will probably see any kind of
platform integration as well okay so
then you go to what do the tests do and
I talked a little bit about that earlier
because the test will generally show you
the use cases for this disco based like
what are the because especially because
we're looking at integration / system
tests unit tests are very useful for
many things and endless but and in this
case also if you make changes or you're
looking at a specific function but
generally you are looking at much bigger
things you're looking at the whole
codebase trying to figure out which
parts are interesting and and therefore
the integration or the system tests are
more useful because these exercise the
entire application I will show you how
it is exercised and what kind of use
cases yeah it will show you how to run
it which you might not be know how to do
and I will show you in the general use
cases but it would also give you an
opportunity to like copy one test and
try to modify it a little bit so it
needs the requirements that you are
what you're looking at let's say that
you are trying to figure out an error so
you're trying to set up a test that can
reproduce the error that you're seeing
in your own application and that's a
very nice thing to do because it's it's
basically every time you want to go
through it you can just press the Run
button
instead of having to go through your
application and doing all of the things
to get to the error if you can set up a
reproducible test case that's also
something that you can submit as a bug
report to this framework right so you
can write tests examine your assumptions
you can say like ok so I think that if
this happens then this other thing
should happen and then you can run it
and you can see if your assumptions are
true and then we come to 5 which is
refactoring refactoring is probably the
most dangerous of all of the techniques
and I I kind of got into it earlier and
the reason for that is refactoring is
opinionated there is no reason you would
submit a refactoring as a pull request
to a project unless you thought that
your refactoring was better than what
was there already
the submitting and refactoring as a pull
request is criticism because if it was
worse or the same as it was before there
would be no reason so so by the very
nature of it a refactoring is criticism
and it's probably a bad place to start
so using refactoring as a learning
technique requires something because
this is psychologically difficult for
people to do because we're in fact
requires work so before you start this
don't get attached to it you have to
know this is stuff you're going to throw
away
you're not going to submit this pull
request you can do all the refactoring
you want you just have to know that
tomorrow or the day after there is there
will be a get reset heart in my future
this thing is not going to live and that
is something that is kind of hard for
people to do because you've invested all
of this work into it
and you probably think it's better but
it is a really bad place to start so
think of this as throw a coat and and do
it as a learning exercise okay so then
we come to reading Maine and I say Maine
in quotation marks because it doesn't
have to be mainly it basically has to be
some function that drives execution in
the part of the code that you're looking
at and drives execution I mean very
often we have classes that are basically
just objects or just just containers for
information and then you have an you
know we used to talk about model control
view some people still do and this would
be more like your control type of
classes things that actually have
functionality and here you will try to
figure out what are the core functions
there and these these I would actually
recommend reading because what drives
execution will generally have important
logic like if it is an actual main
function it will have oftentimes your
main loop if you're in a if you're in
some kind of framework that will expose
this to you and it will have the
beginnings of your event handling so I
would I would suggest reading it top to
bottom because it is it usually holds a
lot of important logic and a lot of
important objects like these are the
central classes in this code base that
build like the core parts also I would
look for for common types like things
that are passed around or if you're
using some kind of a dependency
injection framework then then look at
what is injected into everything because
it's like if you have some one specific
class that is a single school or
something similar to a single that is
injected to everything it probably
contains really important stuff so take
notes draw it out try to figure out how
this works and you don't have to like
you don't have to finish everything you
can just do something put it aside later
when you learn something else you pull
it back and you're like ah okay
so that's the reason that thing it comes
in there and this is a recursive process
as well so you might have to go through
a couple of layers because people have a
tendency to want to like clean up this
main function and make like some
functions that take care of things so
you might have to go through a couple of
layers okay so we talked a little bit
about the graphical layouts and where is
this button and following input events
but there are there's a specific part of
the layout code which is really
important to look at so this is if
you're looking at a GUI application and
you want to know how the GUI application
itself works because we looked at the
layout and that's that's more of a
declarative part of your GUI application
and then the inputs events is more of
your GUI framework but this is about the
application the GUI application itself
so we're going to look at what I call
the main layout and the main layout is
the best way to describe it is if you
look at an application and like Gmail
for example the first thing we go to
Gmail you've never gone there before you
get this paste will go like okay you can
sign up okay and then you click okay I'm
going to sign up and then you can log in
and then after you logged in you come to
your list of messages and then you might
want to open an email and want to
compose an email the the things that are
important about what I'm saying is first
of all they are like clear use cases
there are like you can describe it to a
UX designer it's like yeah open email
compose email login those kinds of
things but also what you will see is
that the whole window changes it's a
totally different layout of the whole
window this is like very very different
and you have to transition between one
look in the layout and a totally
different one and finding the code where
this is done this changing the entire
window contents that is what I call the
main layout and if you look at that you
will generally find what
and if you have developers that have
done a lot of GUI applications you will
find an explicit state machine here
where basically you have where in the
logging in state if login is successful
we will go to the logged in state they
will actually have explicit transitions
between different states but most places
people haven't really done GUI
applications a lot before so you what
you will find is a lot of bullets like
is user logged in and you know is
composing email all sorts of things like
that like a whole bunch of billions and
then you have lots of if statements like
if user is logged in and is viewing
emails and those kinds of things but if
you can find that code that is a very
central part of that is the core part of
a GUI application and it's the one
that's going to switch between the
different layouts between the different
functionalities and then we come to
runtime investigation Wrentham
investigation is very popular as
especially for people are used to
working on back-end
and I will look a little bit at that
because if you have something that is
mostly synchronous if you have an
application that you're looking at which
is mostly synchronous and this is true
for things like command line tools but
it's also true for back end because back
in is like yeah you have many threads
and yeah you might do a little bit of
threading a little bit of async but not
that much because you still have to wrap
it up because you have to get a
responsive back so back end developers
are used to working and generally a
mostly synchronous applications and if
you are working in a mostly synchronous
application of the debugger is awesome
because basically you just set a
breakpoint wherever you're interested in
and then you just step through the whole
thing it's very great so if you are used
to working back in you're usually very
comfortable using your debugger however
if your front-end developer you're
working in a code base that is generally
asynchronous which basically means you
keep on having handlers for things so
when this happened
this thing should happen and then you
have to send a request to the back end
so you that's also asynchronous and then
when that comes back then you have to do
something but then something might have
happened in between and it's a very
different way of coding so using your
debugger for a front-end developer is
not as comfortable and the flow is not
as comfortable and that is something
that you kind of have to to realize when
especially if you're a back-end
developer and you start to do front-end
that you just don't feel like you get
the flow and that's because it's just
harder so what you often do is he used
logging and and then you feel again and
you feel a little bit unprofessional
because you're you're logging a lot but
basically the idea of logging is that
you insert logging many many places and
then you run the application you see and
you do your scenario and you see which
logging statements you actually hit and
then you put breakpoints on all of your
logging statements and then when you hit
the first one it's like and you step
through the code there and then you come
to some async stuff so then you just do
continue and then you will hit you other
breakpoint and this way you can kind of
do semi good debugging of an
asynchronous application which involves
just continued break continued break
continued break then you have something
that that it has hard deadlines this is
the these are these are very difficult
to to to debug because if you break then
then some kind of deadline will will
break and then the whole process will
kind of just end or you will skip a
frame or you will do something so if you
have something that is real-time in some
kind of way then then oftentimes what
you will do is you will do printf
debugging especially if you have like
let's say that you have something that
fails one out of a thousand times you
can't step through it and find the error
because it only fails one out of
thousand times so what you want to do so
you want to love a lot and then you want
to look at that log and see what is
different the times offense and then you
have the idea of using a profiler and a
profile can be very interesting from
many different ways like you
so if you have a scenario where
sometimes it's really slow this can show
you show you what is really slow which
part of it to look at because very often
especially with optimizations people
have a tendency to imagine like I think
probably this part is the part that is
low and of course everybody says you
should measure and and but the profiler
can also give you more understanding on
how things actually work you might not
realize that certain parts take a long
time and that might be useful
information so we looked a little bit at
the different architectures already but
I I kind of want to split it up so if
you were in an event-driven application
and this is generally something that is
asynchronous because of some kind of
constraint so in a GUI application is
highly asynchronous because you don't
want to block the UI you don't want to
like if you click a button everything
freezes until something happens and
because you don't want to block the UI
you constantly have to dispatch
something and when it's finished it has
to come back and some kind of handler
will have to be handling it but this is
true for many other different
applications as well as long as you have
hard deadlines so any kind of trading
system or anything like that anything
that has hard deadlines will have an
event-driven architecture but if you are
more of a request handling architecture
so this is more of a back-end type of
thing you will generally spawn one
thread per request so just you'll have a
thread pool you'll spawn a thread for
that request and then you go back to
listening again and if you have a
command-line tool that is that it's even
more synchronous and and less
problematic than the others because you
got an input you have to produce an
output so it's and then you finished
so you can use the debugger to examine
your runtime state and your stacks and
we looked at that a little bit in the
final and finding the button you can
read the logs to see the flow this is
how the the control flow is when I'm
here and this happens then I end up in
this other file over here and then you
can use the test to drive the flow so
you can construct the flow that you want
to test the one that you want to examine
you can add lots of logging and you
probably will this is where having it in
and source control is really good
adding tests and assertions but I would
also say if you really want to learn a
code base try to add a feature you don't
have to actually push it you don't have
to it doesn't have to be a real feature
but having trying to add a feature
involves a different kind of
understanding because very often you
will think you understand and you'll go
like ok yeah that's fine above a bar but
the moment you have to do it suddenly a
lot of problems occur and you realize
all of the places that you didn't
understand so that brings us now to
reading a class a lot of the other
techniques were about trying to narrow
down the focus let's say that you have
six hundred thousand files which 10
files aren't interesting because you
have to narrow down to something that
you can actually process but now you're
coming down to smaller and smaller code
and and in reading a class there are
certain techniques that are useful first
look at and what kind of interfaces does
it implement but even more than that I
would probably say who uses it in how so
try to do find the usages and look at
the calling code the client code the
people who are calling this class how
what do they use it for which functions
do they call because you could look at
just the public functions and that would
be fun but very often what is public is
sort of random and what you want to do
is what is really the interface what do
the clients of this class actually look
at
what do they use and how do they use it
and often the public functions contain a
lot of other stuff like getters for
example so the moment you get to the
point where you figure out this is like
the 1 or 2 functions of this class that
are like super important then you treat
them like names these are the function
that are driving the execution of this
class the class generally has lots of
properties and things and safe that it
holds but these functions are the ones
that show how it uses the state to
accomplish something and then that leads
us to the last one which is retelling or
rubber duckie
so rubber ducking is something that many
people might have heard of I'm not a big
fan of the word because it is or the the
phrase because I don't think it really
works because the idea and rubber duckie
is basically that you have a literal
rubber duck on your desk and then you
explain stuff to a rubber duck now this
has two problems first of all people
will think you're crazy and it won't
work in like an open-plan offices like
everybody's like had like acting like
normal people and there you are talking
to the duck and the other thing is it's
very hard to be motivated to actually
explain anything to a rubber duck it
just feels dumb and you probably won't
do it so I I would rather go for a
retelling and this is something that you
all probably do that is explain it to
somebody and I think probably all of you
have been in a situation where you've
been debugging something and you just
can't figure it out and you're just
totally lost and you don't know what to
do and then you could walk over to a
calling and you go like ok so I don't
get it I don't understand it and they're
like ok so what's going on and they're
ok so first of all I do this thing and
then this other thing and and then you
kind of stop and they're like nevermind
I know exactly what it is and and this
process you can you can also do if
you're home alone like that you don't
have a colleague to explain it to you
can write a blog post it could be
fictionally you don't have to publish it
but you have to have the feeling that
it's real
very often I talk to many people who say
that like 90% of their Stack Overflow
questions they there's they just throw
them away because by the time you have
written the whole question and you
explained all of the stuff and
everything then you know exactly what's
wrong you don't have to post it some
people actually have a tendency to say
okay I will post it anyway and then just
as and just say that you know this is
how I found it out but having having the
motivation of trying to make somebody
else understand means you have to put in
some effort you can also try to write
documentation
one of the things that I've seen as a
couple of times actually is people who
are maintaining a project and they're
going to pass it over to somebody else
and so they're like okay so I probably
should write some documentation because
it probably hadn't I was like okay so
I'm gonna sit down I'm gonna write a
readme I'm going to show so it's much
easier for the next person to you know
take over but while they're writing the
readme and then it turns out the readme
was like this long and it involved lots
of manual steps and everything and then
you go like I should probably automate
some of this by the time they're done
with the readme they've done a massive
refactoring in the readme in this chart
but just the fact that you have to
express it often realizes the weaknesses
and both in your understanding but maybe
in the code as well and then you have
them you can make an internal
presentation if you feel that you've
spent a lot of time on this and you felt
like okay now I spent a week trying to
understand this framework just to fix
this one bug then maybe you can
repurpose that work to make an internal
presentation and other people might
actually get you know a little bit
smarter from this and yeah ducks aren't
very motivating here one thing that is
important to understand that all of
these ten steps they are like I said in
the beginning it's an iterative process
right it's about doing these things
establish the vague outline then you do
another thing in the list then you flesh
it out and you take your notes you draw
it out
and as you go along you will you will
build up this understanding and that
brings us to the other side what if it's
your project and now this person is
coming in and you want to be a welcoming
project you want to be successful you
want the team to be great what can you
do to set your team up for success so
this is going to build on some research
around what means what team excellence
is about because what is the predictor
of team excellence and this was a
question that Google asked themselves
and they made something that's called
project Aristotle how many people have
heard a project Arizona before yeah and
and what they said was that printed what
they found out in the end was that the
predictor of of team excellence is
psychological safety this was surprising
to them this is not what they thought
they thought that what you would see is
an aggregate of all of the excellent
individuals would make more excellent
hope but what they saw that was that the
individual excellence was not a
predictor for Team excellence and this
was a big problem in the research for
this project because they didn't
understand they got results but they
didn't understand that and then they
came over some research that another
that a woman had done and we'll look at
that which explained the results they
were getting and that is Amy Edmondson
she she wrote something called
psychological safety and learning
behavior in work
I'll read the ad the quote the term is
meant and there's a psychological safety
the term is meant to suggest neither a
careless sense of permissiveness nor an
unrelenting positive effect but rather a
sense of confidence that the team will
not embarrass reject or punish someone
for speaking up this confidence stems
from mutual respect and Trust among team
members
now her research was in not nit it was
in teams in general and it has to do
with with if you want to contribute
everything that you have you have to
feel that if you say something then
people won't jump on you because if you
are in the team work where the tone is
really harsh then you will think twice
before opening your mouth and saying
something and the problem is then we end
up with with people not speaking their
mind and not contributing everything
that they have and I spoke I spoke to
someone recently who had this specific
problem in their team and they said you
know what when when this other person's
pull requests come in I don't say
anything even though it's bad or there's
something wrong I don't say anything
because it always ends up blowing up in
my face and I'm like okay so what
happens when you do something oh this
person is all over everything I do and
then you end up with the weird thing
where where somebody will actually get
all of their bad code hints of the code
base because nobody wants to take that
fight but what is psychological safety
really and I I will try to explain that
in terms like that you will know and
this is this is a myth Amy and Lynn so
she has this matrix trying to explain
the different types of of levels of
psychological safety so first of all you
have the idea of psychological safety
going up motivation and accountability
going to the right and the first one is
if you're low on motivation and
accountability and you don't feel
psychologically safe you come into
apathy apathy is it's meaningless
there's no point there's no point in
doing anything nothing really matters
nobody cares what I say it's you know
yeah I'll I'll do stuff a lot of people
end up here if they're bullied in the
workplace it you you feel like there's
no point because nobody listens to you
nothing you can do really matters
because
people will throw it away or disregard
everything you do if you are in a team
where you might still not be very
motivated but you feel psychologically
safe and you end up in comfort covering
is the thing that most employers are
really afraid of that you know you're
just going to be like it's nice to go to
work and I'll drink some coffee and you
know you won't really do anything cause
it's like who cares about this thing
that we're making but you know I have
nice colleagues and I'll just be here
you have studies where people say like
like is your job meaningless and you
know you have 15% that's a yes okay they
are in the comfort or in apathy okay so
they're basically going like probably
nobody needs to do this job but you know
I'll show up for the coffee and the
money right the thing is in tech this is
not very common most people who work in
tech are highly motivated no matter what
they do it's it's it's it's great it's
like you put somebody to do any kind of
a mundane like programming task and they
will be highly motivated not necessarily
because of the product but because of
the process they will feel it's
important to get it right it's important
to have like a good style and the
quality and and like all sorts of
attributes about the thing that they
care about so people in tech are
generally highly motivated but what
happens if you're highly motivated but
you don't feel psychologically safe then
you end up in anxiety and this is where
people burnout this is where people are
working and working working and trying
and trying and trying and never really
feeling like it matters or they can get
it to work or they ever get rewarded for
what they do people get really anxious
and people can burn out so all of these
are kind of bad right so what you want
is like the upper right corner so in the
upper right corner you final learning if
you are in a psychologically safe team
where people
listen to you they hear what you're
saying it doesn't mean they have to
agree with you then it's not like in
like a nodding thing we're like whatever
you say is great but you know that if
you say it everything's still fine and
you know that you can say something and
everything is still fine where you're
still a team you still feel good and I
think most of us have had that kind of
team at least at some point in our
career something that we couldn't maybe
put our finger on why it was good but it
kind of just gelled and you're highly
motivated but you feel like you matter
you feel like you matter to your team
and you feel like you contribute so the
idea here is is generally people in tech
are highly motivated you don't really
have to work on making them feel highly
motivated what you need to work on is
making them feel psychologically safe
and that means we have to get into to a
learning mode getting into a learning
mode is when you're taking in new
contributors try to learn from them
they're probably bringing things to your
project that you didn't have already and
this goes especially if you're bringing
in people who are minorities in tech in
some kind of way they have experiences
and that that might bring new stuff to
your project that you didn't know before
maybe you'll get in somebody who is
blind and though they'll give you lots
of insight and how accessible your
application is and maybe you will get in
someone who is is non-binary or
transgender and then will go and ask
questions if they feel safe enough the
last question it's like do we really
have to ask about gender here this I
really matter can we take that away
because that might make feel people feel
uncomfortable or people who are
colorblind which the thing is a lot of
people are colorblind but very few
people talk about it in their teams you
know I wasn't a team once where where we
were looking at the application I'm
going like okay so but but the colors
here I don't know like how will this
work on somebody who's colorblind I'm
wearing a team of four people like I'm
one woman three guys turns out all three
we're called by and none of them had
said anything
turns out parts of the application was
absolutely impossible to read because
the text in the background basically
blended together but nobody said
anything because they were like AUH it's
just me it's like all the blindness is
super super normal okay we talked about
not taking stuff personally and that is
something that the like like yeah but
I'm gonna critique you yeah but you
shouldn't take it personally but if you
really are invested in what you make it
should be personal because you should
take pride in your work you should have
like if you are feeling safe in you you
are highly motivated you are trying to
do good work and that is going to be
personal and trying to pretend like it's
not personal it's not helping because
we're basically just building toxic
environments where people have just mean
to each other
and and and decreases psychological
safety so we kind of have to go in
people are going to take it personally
but that's something that you can take
into account maybe you can formulate
your criticism in a different way and go
like okay so you know what this stuff
over here I love it and this thing here
got much so much better in what you did
I'm wondering about this thing over here
maybe we can do it differently how you
phrase things can make a big difference
in how it is felt on the receiving him
and style we have a tendency to be crazy
about style for some reason that's like
you'll get a pull request and it will do
all sorts of functionals and changes but
somebody will absolutely go crazy about
a missing space or or the curly brackets
are in the wrong place we need to get
over the whole style thing like some
projects they just can't get over the
style thing so these just automated away
because you know then you don't have to
think about it but I think probably
style is a good way to practice on not
getting worked up over stupid stuff just
it doesn't matter it's not functional
just breathe in you can deal it's hot
it's hard I know it's hard but I I think
it's a good practice and most of all to
learn to appreciate other people's code
because it isn't bad just because it's
not yours it might even be better than
yours you might actually learn something
and become a better programmer for it
but it is different to read somebody
else's code because you don't have the
mental machine so you now have to build
the mental machine out of somebody
else's code before you can really
understand it like you would your own
and that is my talk thank you so do you
have any questions people think so but
in my experience is not true because and
that is the reason why is and people
think so because they look at the code
that's not theirs and they and they
don't understand it and then they see
that the formatting and everything is
different and they think that's the
reason why they don't understand it but
the thing is the reason why you don't
understand it is because you don't have
the mental model it is it is alien not
because of the formatting but it's alien
because you don't understand it and and
I think that is also one of the reasons
why code reviews are very hard because
doing a code review you get a dip you
get it sorry you get a dip and maybe of
some code that you don't know so you're
getting maybe basically an excerpt of
code that is representing a mental model
you don't know I mean you're seriously
there's no it's really really difficult
to do code reviews of code you don't
know well and if if you do then you
generally end up with style which is
generally useless but the only one good
thing that I've seen of doing that kind
of code review is its language so let's
say that you have a deep understanding
of doing something the pythonic way for
example then you can give good feedback
in like okay but this you could do in a
more elegant way in a
like this way but it still doesn't give
any feedback on the functionality that
you're looking at right but at least it
is something that is the teaching thing
instead of just uh whipping a dead horse
it's like yeah just and very often we
feel like we have to say something like
somebody was like how could you review
this code and you're like okay I have to
create a critique in some way so then
I'm going to comment on the style yeah
yes yes and very often you will you will
have something that looks really weird
and you're like okay why do you do that
and then they explain it and go like oh
okay because there was some constraint
that you didn't know about which made it
made this necessary in some way yeah any
more questions okay thank you
[Applause]